hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to file now hardly time
could you stop smiling at me friend I
have to carry on with less class or I'll
be seeing you very soon so this has to
do with corrupted data and you exploring
your desktop Oh Soph River little is
lessly and the good at word that diddly
and then fingers don't seem to go the
way you hoped they would go use the
mouse to interact with the environment
watch carefully for chances in the Curt
changes in the curses appearance hi yes
my lovely home and my lovely computer
room situated outside my haunted tree
with my haunted tire swing and my
haunted owl nest oh look a haunted
picture on the wall ooh haunted email
welcome back home sis hope your trip was
all you wanted more heard that the flood
is really good Oh food that's also good
too
not like the food here at home mother is
still burning everything she can and you
know how dad is anyway I just wanted to
send you an email to see how you were
going and how the trip was and planning
a road trip soon so if I head your way
maybe I can crash you yours for a little
while would be nice to catch up face to
face better get back to work
love you sis Lenore oh how sweet
too bad I'm gonna be dead soon why do I
have a face cam constantly going on this
is like a battle of the face cams going
on here hey you're marginally more
attractive than I am so stop it okay
anyway let's see notes things to
remember buy more coffee need more
coffee email Lenore back call mom and
dad finished my video game reviews pay
rent due Wednesday pain fo kill pins
payphone kill that didn't some good
alright look on the Internet
instead of doing all those who hey how's
it going is that that me oh boy I hope
I'm getting all sorts of people on my
profile oh boy was this hello
do that not harm sensor if I want to
play with you
doot-doot doot-doot doot-doot doot-doot
alright then
okay now connect chat so might as well
go on with playing see where that gets
me oh hey I'm gonna review this video
game on the video game reviewer alright
even oh good walk cycle going on there
that game good use a little work hello
hi I like it here good for you I don't
like it here at all I'd rather go home
is that okay with you ignore they were
the high one time if I have a soft
squirrel well as the resident king of
said squirrels I hope you didn't kill
them or even by okay I'm tells me his
games a little bit unsettling oh hi does
that mean they're supposed to be me did
I get here I don't know maybe dark
applier got you jump off oh I love a
jump this games so fun for how much I
told you how much fun this game was
about three seconds ago oh I can't jump
anymore okay I can't mu alright either
close the window to continue why would I
do why would that be the only way to go
[ __ ] [ __ ] you and me that was me but
[ __ ] me you alright then just gonna
carry on like that didn't happen oh hey
hi okay how could you well easily to be
honest it didn't take that much effort
oh okay oh my eyes oh okay alright then
good y'all good they're coming at me
from on the horizon oh boy I'm happy
about this
oh they're taking everything the trees
here are a bit scary yeah you know what
else is scary yeah alright carrying on
then hey hello hi neighbor
how you do huh the squirrel was scared
yeah I would be too
oh that's normal I'm gonna assume that's
normal
Jaime seriously how did I get here once
again I must reiterate probably dark
flyer I can jump now that's a nice
feature
oh it's challenge building good mountain
ah no parallax scrolling those could you
smart mu rarer all right you're cute I
guess
well the way that I could do okay my eye
and cheek bones too sharp I know work on
that well oh this is no fun hey are you
my sister Lenore oh you look fine don't
you well oh there new notes here simple
right keep playing the same the game and
I will let you tell you a bit about
myself okay alright
oh hey not much about the data you
survived the test of time leaving a lot
of questions on answers have I did I
miss looking up in the notes here what
records are still around to this day
claim that the being at red skin was
very tall had for long tendril arms
protruding from its shoulders at an
affinity for sharp metal objects and
like to torture it sacrifices with games
or puzzles this picture depicts the
slaves were possibly the prisoners of
time offering themselves to the deity
okay
can I not do that I don't have any email
with me I'm just gonna
oh my tree is gone my tree has gotten up
and walked away
good to know good to know good to know
that's good you know sit here for a
while okay normal run normal that's what
my tree it must be 3 a.m. it's time for
my tree to start dancing in the distance
alright here we go then more game I love
this game oh they're closer oh good for
hey you know I don't want to be alone I
don't regret what I did you know I do I
regret a lot of things in my life
alright so many things yes I wasn't
gonna hurt it that doesn't mean it can't
be scared oh hey how's it going hey
friend how you doing
mmm all right carry on living in that
skeleton hello me again what is going on
again you know with dark applier you
never know what's gonna happen
alright well didn't make that oh okay
made it ah man I failed one oh I didn't
think that was a volcano before but okay
I can dig it like a lot of things oh
yeah right then whose window okey rawr
oh boy
one new email' huh alright pictures I
have invert back from you hope you're OK
my plans for my trip are going
surprisingly well it seems that
everything is a li aligning just right
I'm meeting up with a few travel
advisers today to set up my stop
locations and stuff I am super excited
to see you again mom and dad have been
fighting again in itself is nothing new
but I thought you should be up-to-date
with this stuff we are a family after
all I was hoping we could go see them
together for the holidays I know they
miss you we all miss you anyway I have
to go see these people lobby says Lenore
so why don't I just leave that's an
option I could get up from my computer
at any time and just leave cuz my tree
is back after it's dancing it doesn't
like the dance for a while gets tired
get it anyway where to start
I've been around for a long time
not sure how long when didyou creatures
start being able to walk and then I
think alright
oh it's B is B Raven alright
okay can't do anything here got to find
out something new about the end barber
number after going over am i doing I'm
looking good like I try my monitor no
whelp indeed LP I guess I'm just gonna
be spell buddy
badou boo oh well that's on my eyeball
now okay not just the white scribbles
but that the game is now an idol okay
version four oh hey how's it going
you're real close to me here I don't
like that being that close to me because
I have personal problems they will never
find them who will never find who well
they're having a good time over there oh
that's weird
squirrel squirrel squirrel squirrel
squirrel sir it is me it's me
maybe alrighty then the guy I give a
kiss to isn't in his skeleton anymore
any wheels on the bus go round and round
round and round round and round
lil mama go round and round I'm God Oh
God is he roasting himself I mean he
hung himself with anything
he himself to be roasted uh ok silent
it's time you know that's five for the
best
alright let's see what happens alrighty
then
more notes I suppose you want to know my
name truth is I have had so many names
and yet I can't recall a single one for
now you can call me file no I'm gonna
call you douchebag mcdu cannot err oh I
know Morse code I don't need to know
this let me just review real quick
alright I'll try my best
Morse code I guess I'm gonna need it huh
oh is that is that wet why is it wet
alright you know what
hey hunger can be
you can keep going goodbye B I did it I
came to know it they were thinking that
he s okay cool
good to know have a have a good one the
game is getting better by the day
delicious and if it's Clara Clara it you
know I love a game that it starts out as
early access and then they keep patching
it repent all right cool regret huh
we're the same blood
hello sir Oh ma'am
I don't want to gender you oh you're
looking good nice teeth I see you brush
a lot and now if you over brush that's
what happened sensitivity is common try
to pick remember I don't work for
anything
I remember god damn [ __ ] who's good
we're good
okay all right Oh aliens why not bring
them into the mix hi didn't you think
that we needed them around here but
maybe we could use a little bit of alien
help oh that's nice we're getting deeper
into this okay close the window to
continue off all right even [ __ ] what
was that what else new alright let's see
I'm not sure what else to say oh I know
how about I tell you a bit about you
your name is Raven you were recently on
a holiday that you didn't quite want to
go on but hey when you have a chance to
go somewhere you take it right who knows
what could happen you have a sister
named Lenore she's very beautiful
you left her a long time ago to suffer
the domestic mediocrity that was your
family home you have no pets no
boyfriend no car no real job you spend
way too much time on your computer
oh and you left your curtains open well
that's all really creepy but I'm not I'm
not bothered by it you your weirdo well
I'm a weirdo crap my webcam on like all
the time which is the most bizarre thing
to possibly do that any human could do
but uh oh you didn't save Medford oh
okay
[Music]
did you miss me oh hi hey stop looking
in my window is that a metaphor with
everything in real life well this these
these six beats
there's my favorite yeah oh yeah that's
the good stuff that's an option I bet it
is
oh hey don't you get it they had to go I
don't get it ah hi
is that is that what's supposed to be
Morse code though that because that
doesn't make a lot of sense
oh yeah just be despots good self I
could have guessed that all right then
how all right whatever it is what it is
death is what death do all right why
[ __ ] why no why would I know I don't
know why I know I don't know anything
hey does it still hurt go home I am home
I can see you
Oh boys it gives my webcams on and I'm
constantly live-streaming my bored
expression is that what it is maybe I
should do that maybe slow guy up would
Oh Oh loveliness Oh Lake of Fire kind of
apocalyptic but you know I can dig it
it's good stuff good stuff oh boy okay I
made it apparently hello Raven that's me
I'm so Raven oh boy here we go
dub care cool huh hey sister um this
this man my haunted tree is not
protecting me at like at all
you're really enjoying the game aren't
you I'll ruin the game for you there's
nothing worse than someone telling you
about the secrets I know you like horror
and thriller movies I can tell by your
DVD shelf in the lounge room I'll allow
drama I've never left my computer room
all right fine then more Morse code I
will eventually remember that what do we
got
gameplay don't stop play Lenore file
file file 5/7 5:17 e-file
oh it's Morse code well they are sending
me a message here so what do we got
starting from the third line I'm just
going to go from there we've got
ourselves a big old bad why oh you so
you I'm guessing uh you what is that one
I am using a reference by the way I'm
using a reference so don't think I'm
pulling this out of my ass ah
you can save her or yourself okay so the
message is you can save her or yourself
okay don't know why I'm given a choice
on this one right buddy be able to be
you can save her or yourself uh but but
above oh hi okay that's new I didn't
know that was in my wall I knew about it
my haunted tree and my haunted tire but
I didn't know about my secret door great
good I love my secret occult books in my
wall it was the last game maybe
seems like seven would be a good final
number for some sort of okay you see it
yet no I don't actually see yet sighs I
have no idea what you're talking about
actually okay oh man they keep lighting
dynamics in this game the game engine is
so much better I don't know what that
says shipped Babu Buddha people blob ooh
that's Braille oh well I can't read
Braille
I don't know Braille at all but I'll try
got the end of Summit deciphering going
on here
he will not yet he will not survive yeah
she will not survive okay she will not
survive I don't know why took the time
to read that out a little bit I could
have done better things my time he will
not survive I get it you gotta kill my
sister I got to meet her I kind of get
done MJ Raven school don't do it
I can't start well spook I can't stop it
impossible or can't do I must continue
Wow we gotta cook it ooh nice on the
wall
grody the nice harder dirt dirt dirt
dirt okay
sure burski okay Lenore okay that's my
sister what am I supposed to do about
that okay all right then I'm just gonna
lie okay got it
well in here to continue I can't wait
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
okay well oh god I gotta go through
another message internet strains isn't
it strange isn't it strange isn't it
strange isn't it strange hi holy hell
what are you doing here and why are you
here is there a message in the
background nope those are your tentacles
okay good for you yes slender douche oh
no there's the same thing you can save
her or you can save yourself that's not
new I already got that
so can't do that anymore can't do the
hidden bookshelf anymore so it is pretty
strange you know it's pretty strange
pretty strange that I'm still doing this
whole Bluebird blabber hey another
version of the game oh why oh why oh hey
that's heart bombs get home hey the tree
hey my tree how you doing it's good to
see Raven Raven don't you see
no what are you gonna do to me oh oh
that Lenore I'm sorry
mmm all right be around Raven Raven come
to me no thank you
I'd rather not she never loved you you
failed her ah can't read that okay
Lenore right
oh hi Lenore you seem to be missing an
eye that my fall Raven Raven play the
game I currently am oh don't know what
that's about
well I'm Raven Raven she's not the same
I know she was missing an odd no oh no
is this the Terms of Service
dearest Raven I suppose the
congratulations is in order you finished
the game I'm impressed you made it this
far the noir had troubles convincing me
that you were worth the trouble did you
see the signs were you paying attention
can you understand the game Lenore she
was strong so strong not physically
obviously but mentally remember when I
pulled their eye out she barely even
screamed to be fair she was exhausted
from screaming out for you she wanted to
see you again
before you call me a monster you should
know that it wasn't easy for me either
it's hard to keep someone conscious
enough to talk while you cut into them
Lenore was alone she died alone as did
the little girl the man in the suit and
the lumberjack they all received the
game too
you were the first one to complete it
now if you will excuse me I have some
matters to attend to
his gift from me to you love file
I win Oh No Oh No okay I guess the end
is a disambiguating where maybe I'm
gonna be fine but my sister is dead why
I have no idea I have no idea end of the
depths of this story but I gotta say it
was really well delivered I liked it a
lot there's a little bit of puzzle
aspect of it with the Morse code and
whatnot and it did give you a reference
sheet to go why ah and little things but
maybe there were also hidden details in
the game that I did not see right away
but even so that was pretty good I liked
it a lot not like this guy little bit
splendorous but you know not too bad
more of a digital era Slender Man than
anything else so it's pretty good Oh
does this derive from like an actual
creepypasta I would hope so but either
way not bad at all I liked it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought I found a
comment below and if there's other
secrets to be told
tell your fellow viewer what that's all
about oh yeah that's a lot of people
watching this so tell them if you got
secrets share them with the class thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]